on this wednesday night delays
conflict and confusion the blistering
report blasting ontario's covet 19
response
and the repercussions we found that the
province was clearly not adequately
prepared
two provinces two very different
responses restriction
frustration when your house is on fire a
few buckets of water
doesn't really cut it and appreciation
is this sufficient action
i think it probably is trouble for a
mainstay of canadian malls the pandemic
pushes hudson's bay further to the brink
plus the loss of two athletes one of
soccer's greatest players
and the indigenous canadian who blazed a
trail on
nhl rinks
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
the longer this pandemic goes on the
more it's clear politics is playing a
role in the response especially
in alberta and ontario we'll get to
alberta in a moment
first though a scathing assessment of
the job premier doug ford and his team
have done
in ontario the auditor general says poor
emergency preparedness
inadequate lab capacity and a
disorganized public health system meant
ontario is
slower and more reactive to covet 19
than other provinces
she blames a cumbersome command
structure that's led
by politicians instead of public health
experts
deficient lab and public health
information systems
a fragmented public health system along
with a health command structure
not fully led by the chief medical
officer or dominated by public health
expertise
complicated ontario's response to coven
19.
premier doug ford has always claimed he
has listened to the experts and today he
pushed back against that auditor
general's report
mike gerlay has our top story in the
first few months of 2020 the world
watched as covid19 spread from asia to
europe
it was only a matter of time before
north america would see its first case
but in a critical new report ontario's
auditor general says the province's top
doctors
considered the potential impact of covet
19 to be low
which led to delays conflicts and
confusion
what we're saying is in a time of crisis
the systems that people needed weren't
in place and we're showing what the
consequences of that are
the report says recommendations to
improve the province's emergency
preparedness
were largely ignored and emergency
management ontario was slow to react
in large part because of staffing in
fact ontario had one field officer for
every 1.8 million residents
far less than bc and alberta that's
simply not the case
we acted very quickly we were the first
to
register coronavirus as an infectious
disease that had to be reported
but who was calling the shots the
auditor noted that the large group
tasked with overseeing the province's
response
was comprised entirely of bureaucrats
and politicians
chief medical officer of health dr david
williams wasn't given a leadership role
and only issued directives after
consulting with the command team
an assertion that prompted a strong
rebuke from premier doug
ford but to sit in the office
and throw hand grenades at dr williams
and his team and the minister of health
is totally unacceptable totally
unacceptable
stick stick with looking for value for
money stick
with the job that we hired you for ford
has led the daily provincial briefings
often with dr williams standing in the
wings a fact
not lost on emergency preparedness
experts
scientific evidence and medical
information is a critical part but it's
not the only part
that being said it does send a very
different message
depending on who you choose to have have
the as the face of that
and who's responsible for what different
elements of decision making
the ministry of health was also singled
out for its inability to adapt to the
growing crisis
particularly when it came to testing and
tracing
as recently as october the auditor found
it took as many as four and a half days
to begin managing a positive case
which coincides with the beginning of
the second wave
a surge that shows no sign of leveling
off
microlight global news toronto
not everyone is following the public
health rules and one toronto restaurant
owner decided to keep defying them today
adam skelly now faces several charges
because he opened his restaurant again
today claiming it is his right
the city's top doctor ordered the place
closed yesterday because in-person
dining is banned in toronto right now
hundreds of supporters showed up today
many not wearing masks or physical
distancing
dozens of police officers arrived too
along with some health officials and a
city councilor who called the whole
scene
a circus the restaurant closed again
late this morning
in alberta where covid 19 has been
spreading virtually unchecked the
premier says civil liberties have to be
protected
the province has now reached 500 deaths
and in the last 24 hours
more than twelve hundred new cases were
reported jason kenney
did declare a public health emergency
yesterday but then issued only modest
restrictions
indoor social gatherings are banned but
businesses including retail and clothing
stores can stay open if they reduce
capacity to 25 percent
casino slot machines stay open at
reduced capacity and so do churches
restaurants can still offer in-person
dining here's why
kenny rejected tighter restrictions it
would also be an
unprecedented violation of fundamental
constitutionally protected rights and
freedoms
kenny calls his approach balanced others
have
less charitable words to describe his
leadership and say
what he's doing will lead to more deaths
not fewer
heather eurix west explains
jordan cerrenti's calgary restaurant may
be free to remain
open to customers but the dining room
here at paddy's barbecue and brewery
has been shut down we chose to close
we've been watching the rise in numbers
it's been getting scary cerrenti says as
covet 19 cases rose in alberta the
number of people willing to visit his
restaurant
fell it's why he says he was
disappointed to hear the province wasn't
doing more
to bring the virus under control
obviously it's quite clear
that the jason kennedy was trying to
strike a balance
between a number of different impacts
opposing positions amongst
his his mlas in his cabinet and
albertans generally
today alberta's government is announcing
stressing the importance of protecting
rights and freedoms the premier called
the new restrictions announced tuesday
the minimum required to safeguard the
health system
but there are questions around whether
those minimum restrictions
go far enough quite frankly when you
look at a province like alberta and the
cases that they're having there they
really should be
doing everything they can to not only
stop the rise in cases but they need to
start to see a decline in cases
the province's icus are already near
capacity and in a situation where every
day
counts the province's biggest new
restrictions shutting down schools for
grades 7 through 12
doesn't take effect until next week
what's going to end up happening
is we're going to end up in a prolonged
deeper lockdown that was necessary we're
going to have more dust than where
necessary
and i'm afraid this doesn't get a pass
from from our group
because of how the disease progresses it
takes about 10 days after infection
before a patient might need hospital
care
the fate of the next few weeks is
already sealed and hospitals are bracing
for impact
but what's not known is what will happen
next and whether jason kenny's gamble on
finding a balance
will truly be enough to protect the
province's health system
for everyone heather urex west global
news calgary
the approach in nova scotia couldn't be
more different from alberta
16 new covid 19 cases were reported
there and the premier
decided this week it is time to take
tough action as of midnight tonight
strict new limits are being imposed on
people's lives
and the premier has told nova scotians
to stay the blazes home
over christmas ross lord reports
in the maritimes the second wave of
covet 19 has finally arrived
making it a struggle to ride out the
pandemic safely
at this free rapid testing site there
are long lineups
many are university students part of the
18
to 35 age group where the virus is most
common
now i have heard of people who go to dao
and live down the street from me
testing positive so so it is within the
dalhousie community
a sudden come down after atlantic
canada's remarkable success against the
virus
as covet 19 swept across north america
one corner of the continent remained
mostly unscathed atlantic canada now
that the second wave is spilling into
this region
that remarkable distinction is in
jeopardy the government order means
there will be no
in-person dining at restaurants or pubs
for at least two weeks
public gatherings will be limited to
five people
and retail stores are being told to
limit the number of shoppers and
staff to one quarter of their capacity
the province is discouraging in-store
shopping for black friday
and even christmas shopping in person we
couldn't continue to operate with the
employees in with the
anxiety that they were feeling joe
mcginnis is isolating after a
precautionary covert 19 test
his halifax pub is closed hopefully for
weeks
not months we were certainly the envy of
north america
we can be there again with decisive
action and um and and people need to
follow the rules
easier said than done it seems eight
months after the pandemic started
is this sufficient action i think it
probably is
um the fact that they are seemingly
overreacting
to what to what some people would
perceive as a small number of cases i
think is a good sign
more turbulence in an unsettling time
ross lord global news halifax
british columbia recorded 738 new cases
today
294 people are in hospital including 61
in intensive care and provincial health
officials are clarifying the most recent
numbers they say over the past week
there were some errors that resulted in
over reporting and
under reporting the numbers among the
public health orders masks are now
mandatory in all indoor public spaces in
bc but as robin gill reports
tougher targeted restrictions might be
needed in one region
where numbers are spiking burnaby
general hospital is in the heart of
british columbia's pandemic hot spot
and there's an outbreak here the
hospital is in a large and sprawling
suburban area
outside vancouver known as the fraser
health authority
and a majority of cases are here and
multiplying
but infectious disease experts say this
surge is consistent with a second wave
of the virus
as soon as we lose track namely the
contact tracing
system gets overwhelmed by the number of
cases in the community then it's a
larger problem
and if you look at alberta or ontario
right now they're having those
challenges
you have to keep your mask on the health
crisis is getting resistance
at this grocery store in bc's southern
interior
security had to be hired to ensure
shoppers mask
up get out i'm asking you to leave
scenes like this
prompted the province to make masks
mandatory in public places
with fines set at 230 dollars and it
could be more
if customers are belligerent they do not
have the right to endanger
other people's health it's time for this
small minority to uh
to shut up grow up and mask up a week
ago the province's top
doctor was opposed to mandatory masks
that's
changed it is one of those layers that
has become
incredibly important as we're seeing
this surge in our community here in bc
schools are still exempt from this
recently implemented rule
even though the medical world has been
asking schools be in
on a mass mandate well i've always been
a bigger fan of masks than dr henry
it's one level of defense against a
virus that doesn't seem to be slowing
down
at least in the most populated region of
bc
robin gill global news burnaby
a different call of duty coming up the
former head of the canadian armed forces
on how he'll lead ontario's vaccine task
force
the former head of the canadian armed
forces has been given a new mission
retired general rick hillier will
oversee covet 19 vaccine distribution in
ontario our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stevenson spoke with hilliard today and
asked
about his new role and his return to
public life mercedes
donna general rick hillier is taking on
one of the most important
and difficult missions in the country a
well-known force of personality
hillier said he simply couldn't turn
down ontario
premier doug ford who only called
hillier to ask him to come on board
last week duty calls and you can't stand
there and say oh i wish they did that i
wish somebody would do this
and and be critical if you will and want
things done and then when the premier of
your province
asked you then you would say no i
couldn't do that duty calls
i've stepped up and i'm going to do my
very best hillary says he doesn't know
how many vaccines the province will be
getting
how they will be distributed or even who
will get them first
or when any of that will happen i don't
have that date to give you
but the vaccine is not expected to roll
out in canada until
january at the earliest hillier says
that gives him enough time to come up
with a plan
while the ford government has fallen
short on other promises like testing
targets and contact tracing
hillier believes this is a no fail
mission i'm confident it's going to come
from the government of ontario
and i'll come out of the private sector
also i know i'm confident we're going to
have the right resources to do it
millions of ontarians are depending on
general hillary's appointment being one
that can get things done
and not political posturing by the
province it is the federal government
that is ultimately responsible for
getting the vaccines
and providing that key information to
the provinces and increasing
sore point with the premiers donna
okay mercedes in ottawa thank you
the latest blow still ahead the pandemic
pushes hudson's bay to close
some stores
a company older than canada itself is
facing an uncertain future
hudson's bay like so many retailers has
been struggling during this pandemic
it is so bad the company has stopped
paying rent on several of its properties
as eric sorenson explains this year more
than ever holiday shopping will be
crucial
to survival the window displays in
downtown toronto have tickled the
spirits of christmas shoppers for
decades
and new ads with the stars of
award-winning shit's creek suggest
tis the season for hudson's bay to make
up for lost time and money
shop the colors of the holiday at
hudson's bay but those iconic hudson's
bay images belie a pandemic ravaged year
and for the bay it got worse this week
the dispiriting picture of locked doors
at its store in coquitlam bc
after the landlord said the rent hadn't
been paid a hudson's bay north of
toronto had its lease terminated over
allegedly unpaid rent
and in quebec a judge ordered the bay to
pay outstanding rent at several stores
hudson's bay defends itself the ceo
telling global news in a statement
the burden posed by the pandemic should
be shared fairly by both landlords and
retailers
some landlords have agreed to make
reasonable accommodations
as for the others he says let the courts
decide i would describe
hudson's bay company as the canary and
the coal mine here for all of retailers
the impasse over rent exposes a deeper
problem for department stores
especially during covet 19. there's a
lot of space but fewer customers
the hudson's bay flagship store in
downtown toronto has an
estimated 850 000 square feet over
several floors
and the bay has a lot of big stores in
ontario alone
more than 30 locations and across the
country
almost 90 hudson's bay stores that's
millions of square feet
at a time when more and more people are
staying home and shopping online
the reality is in covet the shopping
centers are not bringing anywhere near
the traffic that's expected the bays had
to confront not just how people are
buying differently
but what they're buying people working
from home and sweatpants aren't looking
as much for high-end fashions
now a part of the bay's brand that was a
great attempt to reposition the company
and i think
if there had not been the cover this may
very well have worked
quite smoothly during the biggest
shopping season of the year the bay
hopes to keep its hardball
fight with landlords in the background
and to rely on canadian stars to catch
the eye of shoppers
to get through a cold covered christmas
two pairs of uggs
there's 13 of us still two
eric sorensen global news toronto
he was quite simply a soccer legend next
the tributes to diego maradona
unbelievable that was diego maradona
when he was at his best
he had no equal when he was on the pitch
he
was running the show the soccer legend
from argentina
died today at the age of 60. he had a
heart attack at his home in buenos aires
a week after surgery to remove a blood
clot from his brain
drug and alcohol problems engulfed
maradona later in life
but it is the dazzling way he played the
game that's being remembered
today maradona was one of the greatest
of all time
even other legends like pele
acknowledged that certainly
one day we'll kick a ball together in
heaven pele said today
maradona could thread his way through
the best players in the world
his mastery of the game control of the
ball and displays of utter joy
mesmerized fans
and in his homeland of argentina he was
revered
often referred to as the golden boy his
life was a rags to rich's story
he grew up in a slum got his first ball
when he was three
turned pro at 16.
famous for that hand of god goal in 1986
he led argentina to a world cup victory
the country's president has declared
three days of national mourning
you took us to the top of the world he
said you made us immensely happy
you were the greatest of all fellow
argentinian
leonel messi wrote today he has left us
but he isn't going anywhere because
diego
is eternal there has been so much loss
in 2020
and tonight we have the story of a
canadian hockey player who has
passed away he's not famous like
maradona he didn't even play many games
in the nhl
but his story is an important one he was
a trailblazer who opened doors for
generations that followed
here's mike armstrong he beat
just about the longest odds imaginable
fred zazakamoos was 19 years old when he
laced up his skates with the chicago
blackhawks
it was the original six era and he would
do battle with legends like
howe and richard only 125 hockey players
and six teams and i was one of them
it was a very short nhl career but a
long life
and an even longer legacy so saskamoos
is being remembered not for his 11 games
played
but for the fact he played them at all
theo fleury tweeted out that sasaka
moose helped indigenous hockey players
dream big while flyer's great reggie
leach says
as a boy he was inspired from the first
day he heard of sasaka moosa's success
but leech is also remembering the
hardships of his friend's life
sasaka moose would spend most of his
youth at a residential school in duck
lake saskatchewan
he was taken from his family when he was
just six years old with his brother
it was there that he would learn to play
organized hockey but it was also
there that he would live years of
mistreatment
i've been abused i see my brother you
just get abused
you know all that is
i don't think i'll forget it now in
hockey soccer moose would find
friendship with teammates but also
racism from opponents
and fans they were injuries he would
ignore but again
never forget despite all of that
sasaka moose would lead a life of
leadership he would inspire generations
through sports
and community service he spent 35 years
as a band counselor with the attacker
coupe cree nation
when i became a chief in 1980 then
i think it was one of the greatest
things that ever happened to me
to remember sasaka moose with numbers 11
games played in the nhl stands out
but there's also 120 grandchildren
and great-grandchildren another reason
he smiled
so much
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is pender harbor
british columbia
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
you